I would say it's easily in a million
lines.
A million lines of code
Absolutely.
The algorithm is meant to
indicate all of the different methods
We use who decide which search results we'll
going to show you
and in what order for which
recommendations we'll going to choose for you
I think people when they refer to the
algorithm they mean all the code
that we've written to do those things
I don't think of it as one thing, I think
of it as lots of little pieces that are
trying to accomplish the overall goal of
connecting you with what you're looking for
or what we think you might want
to watch
it's not like a piece of code hidden in
a safe or something
(Laughter)
there's no piece of code hidden in a
safe
there's a lot of code and it scattered
all over the place in our code base
if you look closely at it it will
resemble much more accounting than any
sort of dark sophisticated thing.
there is whether it's the algorithm or
whatever is there is a degree of secrecy
is in there for good or bad reasons
I mean you you can't be completely open
about all of this, can you? or you're not
open about all of it seems
is that a fair comment?
I mean I think
we're quite open about what we're trying to achieve
and I think we're open about
the instances where we know it's not
working and we think it could be better
I tend to be a little bit more reticent
to discuss exactly how we're doing it
and there's a few reasons first of all
we don't want people to try to game
what we're doing and sadly we do see
that on YouTube and so everything do we
have to think about the opportunities
for gaming it I mean we're using certain
kinds of information to help people find
the videos they're looking for
That depends on on that being that
information coming from sincere viewers
who were actually looking for things
now if instead it came from a robot
it wasn't really looking for anything it
was just trying to make sure that a
particular video showed up at the top of
some search results are you know how to
tremendous number
views then then we can't use that
anymore and so it's not just that
there's a few more instances of poor
search results or inflated view counts
but but it's worse than that because
actually that's what that means that
that we can't use the thing that we were
using anymore and so now we have to
you know, we have to take that away as a
possibility for helping associate
the viewers with the videos they want to
watch and then move on to the next thing
and then of course that thing may also
be abused and so, you know, we have to
try to protect these these signals as we
call them so that so that we don't lose them
and you know that and then we're left
with very little to actually go on
I don't want to lock us into a
particular way of doing things
you know say for instance that five
years ago
ranking the search results by the view
count may have been a great thing to do
and that was because at that time
view count was one of the best signals
that you could find for what are the
quality of the video
well since then we've found other things
that are even better
and we don't want people to become upset when
they say hey wait a minute these videos
are ranked in the order of the view
count
that's wrong what's not wrong because we
like I said we would have done an
experiment to find that there was
actually a better way to do it yes we
take the view count into account but
there's some other thing that we might
want to do for instance a very good
example is if it were just ranked by
view count you've never seen any new
videos
so you type plane crash after a plane
crashes and you'd see the oldest plane
crash footage we have if we want to have
some video of the new incident
we can't rank everything by view count
we don't want to commit ourselves
in a way two people thinking that this is the
way it has to be and that we can't make
any changes because where we have to we
have to make changes
you mentioned view
I mean view account is very transparent
signal because of the design of YouTube
can you mention some of the other
signals you're using
sure what one of those that we started using
a couple of years ago now I guess what
was watch time. So what we noticed was
that was that when people looked for
videos
it was often the case that they would
see one that looked like the video they
wanted to watch but then once they got
on that watch page it wasn't actually
the video they wanted to watch
maybe it had a thumbnail that was you
know very misleading or title that was
particularly misleading
now fortunately in most of those cases
eventually they got to the one they were
looking for and often that was because
that would be somewhere on the related
videos but in looking that situation we
thought when 'Gee that's kind of crummy'
because why should I have to click two
or three times in order to finally get
to a video that I was looking for
we tried to figure out how to fix that
went well people tend to know fairly
quickly whether or not the video they've
landed on is the one they're looking for
the best example I remember of this was
we saw one where there were several
videos that had titles about a
particular boxing match and one of them
especially had a thumbnail of a guy like
he was just about to be hit and miss you
know its fist was right up in the other
guy's face and everybody was going to
click on that one
what turned out that the video behind
that was a person talking about that
fight and it had no footage of the fight
and eventually the viewers would finally
get to the one that had some footage of
the fight when we looked into that
situation we realize that one way to
detect the difference between these was
one of these videos wasn't getting watch
very much and the other one was once
very loan or watch for very long exactly
one of them wasn't getting watch very
long and the other one was and so
instead of just ranking the videos by
how often they were clicked in response
to a query we rank them for how much
they they were watched in response to a
query and so that helped that situation
quite a bit
how often are you twiddling the dials
and refining this and tweaking - is
like a daily thing with little things
that can change or is it like a
once-a-year big implementation
we've we've always got at least I don't
know ten different changes that were
working on and they may take somewhere
between a few weeks to several months to
finally launch and there's usually some
some analysis and intuition and then
there's some implementations some
changes that you're going to make to the
code and then there's lots of
experimentation and evaluation in order
to confirm that this change actually
benefits the viewers and so how many
times do we do in a year maybe 50 times
a year or a hundred times a year
other things that believes that can be
pulled like okay today we're going to
put twenty one percent emphasis on watch
time and no no it needs to be nineteen
percent is it is it like that or not
um it's not really like that because all
of those settings or levers or or all
the code that we've written to make
those kinds of decisions has been has
been tuned based on evaluation and
analysis of some kinds of experiments or
other ways we have of rating changes and
so it would make sense for us to walk in
and saying like you know I'm feeling
like we ought to put a higher weight on
something even if i were to feel that we
ought to put a higher weight and one
watch time for instance what that would
amount to is some of the engineers doing
several weeks worth of experiments to
see whether or not putting a higher
weight on watch time resulted in more
people getting to the videos they
watched faster
we can see
the data that we've got about now the
data that we get back is completely
random it depends where when the server
crew received that message to put in same
computer's memory
so this time we're on it is actually
giving us some use for the information
because when we have demonstrated some
evidence you know in the broader subject
another way that we might find to
recommend things too